schreiben Leute denken
vielleicht ein zwei Worte noch zum
Schreibzentrum der LMU für diejenigen
die es nicht kennen unser Kernangebot
richtet sich an Studierende und an
Promovierende und
die wichtigsten
Angebote sind einerseits individuelle
schreibberatungen und andererseits
unsere freitags-workshops in denen es
eben um Themen rund ums wissenschaftlich
akademische schreiben geht
unsere Grundprinzipien sind dabei
einerseits Hilfe zur Selbsthilfe also
wir wollen nicht
Studierenden irgendwelche Lösungen
fertig präsentieren sondern in unseren
schreibberatungen geht es darum
gemeinsam auf ein Schreibprojekt zu
gucken in der Regel kommen die
Studierenden oder auch Promovierenden
mit ja Schwierigkeiten vielleicht auch
Hemmungen und da geht es dann darum zu
gucken wo hakt es denn im Schreibprozess
wo kann man da ansetzen und dann eben
gemeinsam
Lösungsansätze zu finden bzw IDE
normalerweise die Rat suchenden
Selbstauflösung kommen zu lassen
und das ganze läuft bei uns auf Peer to
peer-basis das heißt wir haben eine
ganze Reihe von ausgebildeten schreibt
peer-tutor:innen die einerseits die
Schreibberatung machen und andererseits
auch die freitags-workshops
was wir jetzt
immer wieder feststellen ist dass wir
natürlich auch von den Kapazitäten an an
unsere Grenzen kommen also wir sind
prinzipiell für alle Studierenden
geöffnet
also auch fachübergreif fachübergreifend
aber ja wir sind eine für die LMU immer
noch verhältnismäßig kleine
Einrichtungen die Mittel die wir zur
Verfügung haben sind auch projektbasiert
also immer wieder beschränkt und
es gab schon vor einer Weile
ein Projekt ein multiplikatorenprojekt
was damals noch aus leere LMU Mitteln
gefördert wurde und da ging es dann
darum
stärker mit Lehrenden zusammenzuarbeiten
und die das schreibtdidaktischen
Know-how was bei uns am Schreibzentrum
sich ja über viele Jahre entwickelt hat
weiterzugeben zu multiplizieren
[Musik]
die Fortbildung schreibt Didaktik und
die ist jetzt heute und morgen gehen
soll
ist
ja quasi zu denken als Fortsetzung von
diesem von diesen Bemühungen mit
Lehrenden zusammenzuarbeiten und
Schreiben direkt und stärker auch in die
fachlehre zu integrieren weil das
Kernangebot was wir haben
ist jetzt erstmal direkt für Studierende
für Promovierende
[Musik]
und da können wir
ja
viel erreichen bei individuellen
Studierenden aber wenn wir mit Lehrenden
anfangen zusammen zu arbeiten und das
quasi unser Know-how ja am besten im
ganzen Mittelbau ausbreiten dann stellen
wir uns vor das ist natürlich ein
wesentlich größeren Effekt geben kann
das ist eben die eine Ebene die andere
Ebene ist natürlich dass Schreiben
wissenschaftliches Schreiben bei uns
da wir auch fachunabhängig agieren
natürlich nur bestimmte eher universelle
allgemeine Aspekte des
wissenschaftlichen Schreibens fassen
kann viel passiert ja aber auch in der
Fachlehrer also es gibt einfach
fachspezifische Aspekte beim akademisch
wissenschaftlichen Schreiben die wir in
der Tiefe so auch gar nicht abdecken
können
das heißt wenn wir sagen Integration von
schreiben in die Lehre dann heißt das
wir möchten Lehrende gerne dazu anregen
verstärkt auch kleinere Schreibaufgaben
in die fachlehre zu integrieren und die
Fortbildung schreibt Didaktik die eben
an dieses an diese Idee an dem Gedanken
anknüpft schreiben und schreib Aufgaben
schreibt Didaktik stärker in die
Fachdidaktik zu integrieren
die basierte oder da kam noch eine
weitere Idee hinzu also wir haben quasi
auf der einen Seite Fach und
schreibtdidaktik wir sagen diese Grenzen
kann man eigentlich mal aufweichen und
auf der anderen Seite war bei der
Fortbildung schreibt Didaktik für
Lehrende jetzt die Idee sie sagen okay
also einerseits ist uns daran gelegen
dass studentisch Schreibkompetenzen
gefördert werden
das kann man zum Teil wunderbar machen
über extra curriculare Angebote wie wir
sie am Schreibzentrum auch bieten
noch besser ist es aber wenn die
studentischen Schreibkompetenzen
gleichzeitig eben auch mit in der
fachlehre gefördert werden
und da geht es uns nicht so sehr darum
dass wir sagen es muss jetzt in jedem
Kurs in jedem Seminar
schreiben
gelehrt werden sondern wir sagen
nutzt schreiben als Methode als Werkzeug
für die fachlehre lasst eure
Studierenden die Fachinhalte sich
schreibend erschließen zumindest zum
Teil schreiben vertiefen
das ist die eine Seite und die andere
Seite und das war jetzt die Idee an der
Fortbildung an diesem neuen Format was
wir im Wintersemester
im vergangenen Wintersemester zum ersten
Mal angeboten haben
ist dass man wenn man sich mit dem
Schreiben auseinandersetzt
und wir sagen das ist im Prinzip ein
Werkzeug für die Lehre genauso kann es
eben auch ein Werkzeug für die eigene
Forschung sein und das ist ja häufig was
was
also ich schließe mich da nicht aus wenn
man eine Lehrverpflichtung hat und
gleichzeitig aber ein eigenes
Forschungsprojekt hat hat man oft das
Gefühl dass eine kommt zu kurz oder das
andere kommen zu kurz
und in der Fortbildung ging es uns auch
darum dass wir eben nicht nur ein Raum
dafür schaffen dass die Teilnehmenden
angeleitet werden wie sie die
studentischen Schreibkompetenzen fördern
können sondern eben auch wie das was
sie da überschreibt die dank dem
schreibforschung Lernen auch für die
eigenen Forschungs- und Schreibprojekte
genutzt werden kann
in dem Sinne das ist quasi die zweite
Ebene auf der wir diese ja eine eine
bewusste Grenzüberschreitung machen
wollen Forschung und Lehre stärker
zusammen denken also das ist ja
eigentlich eh was was zusammen gedacht
werden sollte vielleicht aber
oftmals ja doch in der Praxis sehr
getrennt voneinander stattfindet
heute werde ich wie gesagt mich auf
das Schreiben als verbindendes
lehrinstrument konzentrieren also auf
diese Grenze oder dann schließlich das
zusammendenken von Fakten schreibt
Didaktik Felix bugelmann wird dann
morgen auf das Schreiben als
Forschungsinstrument noch mal stärker
eingehen
wir haben also quasi dieses
zweigeteilte der der Fortbildung
schreibt Didaktik was wir zusammen
gedacht sehen wollen haben wir jetzt
aber auch zwei Tage aufgeteilt aber ich
glaube dass wir da morgen die Verbindung
zurück zum lehrinstrument auch immer
wieder gut hinbekommen
ja ich hatte schon
angedeutet dass
jetzt am Schreibzentrum schreiben
natürlich erstmal einen Lerngegenstand
ist
wenn wir sagen
schreiben soll in die fachlehre
integriert werden
dann ist schreiben da aber nicht mehr
primär lernen Gegenstand sondern wird
zum lehrinstrument und das ist der
Moment in dem Fachdidaktik und schreibt
Didaktik sozusagen ja ineinander greifen
und sehr fruchtbar
werden können in dieser Kombination also
in einer Art Fach schreibt Didaktik wenn
man will und
jeder direkt schon mal weiter
wenn ich sage schreiben ist ein
Instrument für die Lehre dann weiß ich
dass das
ja doch oft noch missverstanden wird
und es kommen dann oft Rückfragen aber
wie soll das denn also wie soll das denn
integriert werden wir haben ja so schon
irgendwie zu wenig Zeit oft für die
Fachinhalte und das ist aber eben genau
der Knackpunkt es geht darum dass die
fachlichen Inhalte die bleiben weiterhin
im Vordergrund aber das schreiben soll
im Endeffekt wie
wie jedes andere didaktische Werkzeug
auch genutzt werden
und das basiert auf dem Gedanken das
schreibt Denkens das haben die ein oder
anderen von Ihnen vielleicht auch schon
mal gehört es ist eigentlich finde ich
relativ intuitiv auch zu verstehen wenn
wir schreiben passiert dabei in der
Regel was also es ist
selten so dass wir irgendwelche
irgendein Wissen haben und das Schreiben
wir auf und das ist im Prinzip im Kopf
schon fertig gedacht gewesen wenn wir
anfangen irgendwas aufzuschreiben dann
entwickelt sich das oft noch und es ist
tatsächlich in der schreibforschung aus
verschiedenen Disziplinen auch bekannt
das Schreiben an sich und sei es nur das
Erstellen von einer Liste einfach eine
epistemischen Effekt hat
und diesen Effekt den kann man eben ganz
gezielt nutzen wenn wir uns davon
verabschieden das Schreiben einfach nur
das Aufschreiben von etwas ist also wenn
man ans Schreiben im akademischen
Kontext denkt
dann denkt man glaube ich oft an das
Verfassen eine Hausarbeit oder einer
Abschlussarbeit und hier geht es eben
ganz dezidiert nicht um große
Schreibprojekte sondern es geht um
kleine
Schreibaufgaben bei denen nicht das
Schreiben im Vordergrund steht also es
steht nicht im Vordergrund dass man
jetzt schreiben oder wissenschaftlich
schreiben lernen soll sondern es steht
im Vordergrund dass man schreiben als
Werkzeug nutzt um sich beispielsweise
einen Inhalt zu erschließen um Inhalte
die im Seminar diskutiert worden sind
noch mal zu vertiefen kritisch zu
reflektieren
was dann und das ist die Idee an dem
Konzept dass man ja kleinere
Schreibübungen die auch unbenotet sein
sollten in die fachlehre integriert
das hat dann eben quasi den positiven
Nebeneffekt das den Studierenden die das
nutzen
gleichzeitig und quasi nebenbei
verschiedene Schreibtechniken Strategien
vermittelt werden so dass
die Schreibkompetenzen um die es uns am
Schreibzentrum ja jetzt erstmal primär
geht dann quasi nebenbei
sich mit weiterentwickeln können
eigentlich ohne dass die dass die
Studierenden merken dass das mit dem
Fokus steht
wie kann das jetzt konkret aussehen also
wie können wir
Fachinhalte vermitteln und dabei
schreiben als Werkzeug nutzen ich hatte
schon gesagt dass es uns dabei eben
darum geht dass Schreibübung begriffen
werden als eines von vielen anderen
didaktischen Werkzeugen ja also dass das
im Prinzip in den ganz regulären
Didaktik Methoden Koffer für die
fachlehre mit aufgenommen wird
wir hatten und die gibt es auch schon
länger eine Sammlung mit
schreibdidaktischen Methoden
zusammengestellt die eben genau darauf
ausgerichtet sind dass man kleine
Schreibaufgaben nutzt um
in der fachlehre voranzukommen
inhaltlich und gleichzeitig aber
bestimmte ja einfach eine
Schreibroutine möglicherweise erzeugt
bei Studierenden Berührungsängste mit
dem Schreiben reduziert und diese
Sammlung die wir in der Fortbildung eben
auch nutzen
um und das ist quasi eines ein out
kommen der Fortbildung um dann einen
ja schreibt didaktisch informiert ist
Konzept für eine Lehrveranstaltung die
man ohnehinhalten muss am Ende vorliegen
zu haben und diese Sammlung die wir da
auch nutzen die es darauf ausgelegt dass
diese Übung die Schreibübung die
Lehrenden entlasten es sind keine
Übungen die darauf
abzielen dass man als Lerner als
Lehrender noch mehr Korrektur oder
Feedback Aufwand hat sondern diese Übung
kommen entweder ganz ohne Feedback auf
also es geht dann um Schreibaufgaben und
um schreiben was wirklich bei den
Studierenden bleibt oder sie basieren
auf viel Feedback
die Übungen sind alle fachunabhängig das
heißt egal aus welchem Fach sie kommen
also von von
ja Literaturwissenschaft über Politik
bis Mathematik Physik man kann das im
Prinzip für jedes Fach nutzen es sind
keine Inhalte vorgegeben
und
die Übung können
tatsächlich zu wenn man möchte das muss
man nicht so machen aber wenn man möchte
kann man das auch tatsächlich als
didaktische Rahmen für ganze
Lehrveranstaltungen nutzen das ist im
Endeffekt das worauf wir in der
Fortbildung auch abzielen das gemeinsam
eben ein Konzept für eine gesamte
Lehrveranstaltung erarbeitet wird bei
denen bei dem Übungen schreibt
didaktische Übung von vornherein mit
vorgesehen sind
die Sammlung enthält aber auch
kurze Übungen also fünf minütige Übungen
die man jederzeit spontan mal mit
einbringen kann man kann es gibt Übungen
die gehen länger da kann man dann
beispielsweise eine halbe oder eine
ganze
veranstaltungssitzung
mitgestalten also das ist relativ
flexibel
ich möchte ein Beispiel geben weil mir
klar ist dass das wahrscheinlich immer
noch relativ abstrakt ist
ich habe das
Gedächtnisprotokoll mal rausgesucht
weil ich glaube dass der Umgang mit
Sekundärliteratur also mit
Forschungsliteratur eigentlich auch für
jedes Fach relevant sein kann also
spätestens dann wenn es irgendwie um
eine Abschluss oder eine
qualifikationsarbeit geht und ich möchte
an dem Beispiel auch zeigen dass man
auch mit den Übungen selbst
natürlich flexibel umgehen kann das
Gedächtnisprotokoll funktioniert so wie
es hier aufgeschrieben ist so dass man
einen kurzen Text oder ein
Textausschnitt mitbringt in den
Unterricht die Studierenden lesen das
bekommen dafür zehn Minuten
legen den Text dann weg oder drehen ihn
um so dass sie eben nicht mehr sehen
sollen dann
fünf Minuten am Stück
möglichst ohne abzusetzen aufschreiben
was hängen geblieben ist also ein
Gedächtnisprotokoll anfertigen dann wird
der Text wieder aufgedeckt die
Studierenden können abgleichen
was habe ich verpasst was wichtig ist
was habe ich aufgeschrieben was
vielleicht eigentlich doch nicht so
wichtig ist
das ist jetzt eben eine Methode die so
mittellang ist man kann das aber auch
anpassen man kann auch sagen weil das
denke ich auch in vielen verschiedenen
Fächern so gemacht wird
wenn Texte zu einer Sitzung zu lesen
waren
dass man dann am Anfang der Sitzung sagt
okay jetzt guckt noch einmal kurz in den
Text oder in das Lehrbuch Kapitel oder
wie auch immer um das es gehen soll in
der Sitzung noch einmal kurz durch
gucken
zur Seite legen
Gedächtnisprotokoll anfertigen noch mal
Abgleich und dann nimmt man das ganze
als Diskussionsgrundlage das hat den
Effekt dass ja einerseits eine
Vertiefung stattfindet der Inhalte also
die Studierenden müssen sich aktiv mit
dem mit den Inhalten auseinandersetzen
wenn sie dazu was aufschreiben sollen
und hat einfach eine ganzen ganz anderes
aktivierungspotenzial als wenn man
einfach so in die Diskussion geht und
was ich auch immer wieder beobachtet
habe ist das Studierende die sich sonst
nicht so viel beteiligen sich dann
plötzlich beteiligen weil sie Zeit
hatten sich Gedanken zu machen was
aufgeschrieben haben sich vielleicht
auch an was festhalten können und ja
dann dann plötzlich bereit sind das zu
teilen wo sie vielleicht vorher gedacht
hätten da bin ich mir jetzt irgendwie
unsicher und jetzt haben sich auch schon
drei andere gemeldet und dann bleibe ich
mal lieber ruhig also das ist eben ein
Beispiel wie das aussehen kann wenn wir
sagen integriert kleine Schreibübungen
in die fachlehre
genau und in der Fortbildung arbeiten
wir eben mit dieser unter anderem mit
dieser Methodensammlung und schauen dann
auf die ja individuellen Bedürfnisse
aber auch auf die fachlichen Bedürfnisse
abgestimmt wie kann
wie kann ich verschiedene kleinere oder
auch größere Schreibaufgaben integrieren
mit dem Aufwand den ich haben möchte
also
es ist zwar so dass es keinen
Mehraufwand geben muss man kann
ausschließlich mit Aufgaben mit
Schreibübungen arbeiten bei den
[Musik]
en die
die von niemandem nachher gelesen werden
müssen
es gibt aber auch also hatten wir in der
Fortbildung auch immer wieder Leute die
das eigentlich sogar ganz gerne machen
dann schon früher in die in die
Interaktion mit den Studierenden gehen
auch um zu gucken wie weit sind die dann
eigentlich mit den Schreibkompetenzen
so
Fachinhalte jetzt sehe ich gerade dass
ich schon einigermaßen
überzogen habe glaube ich
ganz schnell also Schreibkompetenzen
studieren dafür dann das was wir sagen
das passiert eigentlich nebenbei also
die Übung dienen der fachlehre
nebenbei lernen die Studierenden sich
aber auch als schreibende kennen
dadurch dass sie immer wieder ins
Schreiben kommen und auch die Erfahrung
machen dass das nicht immer Texte sind
die jeder sofort liest und die sofort
beurteilt werden wächst einfach ein
gewisses wächstes Selbstvertrauen es
entstehen schreib Routinen das Schreiben
wird als individueller Prozess
wahrgenommen
[Musik]
und man lernt dadurch dass man in
Interaktion auch mit Studierenden kommen
natürlich auch verschiedene schreibtypen
kennen man lernt verschiedene
Schreibtechniken und Strategien kennen
sieht einfach wie schreiben andere wie
sieht der Prozess bei anderen aus davon
kann man sich vielleicht was abgucken
aber natürlich auch die Übung selbst
sind Übungen die Studierende dann wenn
es an die Hausarbeit die Abschlussarbeit
die Doktorarbeit vielleicht irgendwann
geht
nutzen können und zwar bewusst
zum Teil übrigens auch im
Schreibhemmungen abzubauen das ist noch
mal ein anderes Thema